This concludes our Administrative and Regulatory Affairs Budget workshop.
We will now begin our budget workshop for the municipal courts.
And at this time, I would like to welcome Judge Elaine
Marshall and CFO Nellie Santos to provide the
municipal courts budget presentation.
Put the chair up too high.
Thank. Thank you.
Welcome, your Honor. And that floor is yours.
And good afternoon and
council members. I am here and it is my pleasure to present today the Municipal
Court Department's FY 23 Budget.
Attending with me today is McD's Chief Financial
Officer, Deputy Director Nellie Santos, and she's seated with me today as
well as members of my executive team who are in the audience. This presentation
is reflective of our commitment to our community to provide
court services in an equitable and safe manner.
Next slide, please. Our General Fund
consists of seven cost centers, each of them having budgets assigned,
staffed, and specific core services.
This slide includes four of the seven cost centers.
The system support cost. Center has no assigned FTEs.
Next slide. This slide includes
the remaining three General Fund cost centers. Next slide.
Municipal Court also manages four special funds that provide specific
services, including security, technology, and truancy
prevention. The Municipal Jury Fund is our fourth
special fund and currently has no assigned FTEs
or expenditure budget. This is a newly created
fund and expenditures will be budgeted once the fund balance
increases. Next slide, please.
Listed on this slide are McD's major services.
These services help us to achieve our overall goals and our
mission. Next slide.
Our courts are mandated by law to provide a legal forum for
the individuals charged with criminal offenses.
Included in these mandates are the right to a jury trial,
equal access to the legal system, and adherence to our
state and local law. Next slide, please.
Sorry. Oh. Next slide,
please. MCD has
many internal revenue generating initiatives that provide
enhanced court services to the public and assist
municipal courts in achieving its overall revenue target.
These services include passports, weddings notary,
and the printing of driving records to better serve target
areas within our community. We have various specialized
dockets that provide meaningful and safe methods for
case resolution, including the Veterans Court and the Safe
Harbor Court. Judges assigned to these dockets have
the ability to reduce fines, offer payment plans, or other
methods of case resolution to individuals who are experiencing
hardships but who still want to fulfill their legal obligations to
the court. I'm happy to report that Teen Court was able
to resume their in person monthly activities in FY
22. This program has made long lasting impressions
on the lives of our youth by providing a glimpse at the
legal system through firsthand participation and
through mentorship provided by our professional volunteers.
Next slide, please. I think we're
one slide ahead of me now. There we go.
MCD began decentralizing court services many
years ago, anticipating the future growth in the population.
We serve our full service courts can be found in
key areas of the city and they include our central
location, Macawa, West Side and North Command.
We also have annex courts that are open and located
in Kingwood and the Clear Lake areas which are open one day per
week, and a court at the Joint Processing Center which we
perform and they handle jail, dockets and magistrate court services,
and we do those. That court is in operation seven days a week,
22 hours a day, 365 days a year.
We also anticipated the greater use of technology and
have implemented many web based processes.
Our short term messaging service provides text messages
and email reminders to our customers about upcoming scheduled
court dates, as well as important emergency notifications
to address the needs of our diverse community and to allow
full participation in the legal service. We have full time
certified Spanish interpreters as well as access to
other languages through contract services and the language line.
Next slide, please.
This slide represents a comparison of revenue for FY 21,
FY 22 and FY 23 for all MCD
funds and the percentage change between the FY 23
proposed and the FY 22 estimates.
As reflected, there is an overall 3% decrease in revenue
across all funds for FY 23. Next slide,
please. Despite the COVID challenges and the
lower rate of citation issuance, we expect FY 22
General Fund revenues to exceed the budget target.
This increase is attributed to the resumption of all the dockets,
including cases that were delayed during the suspension period.
This increase is also due to the high level of performance from
our internal and external collection teams, McD's revenue
generated initiatives, and the deferred payment program for
FY 23. We project a slight decrease
in General Fund revenue from the FY 22 projection due
to a reduction in the number of backlog cases and a continued
lower citation rates. Next slide, please.
This slide includes revenue highlights for our four MCD
special funds. The annual variances in the revenue
budgets for the funds remain in line with the General Fund
for FY 23. We anticipate a reduction
in the grant funding from the office of the Governor for our Juvenile
Case Manager Truancy Prevention initiative. Through this grant,
we have been able to expand our program to additional schools.
However, this reduction may negatively impact the services
we provide to our partner school districts. Next slide,
please. This slide represents a comparison
of expenditures for FY 21, FY 22
and FY 23 for all MCD funds and the
percentage change between FY 23 proposed
and FY 22 budgets. There is a 2.3
overall increase in expenditures across all MCD
funds for FY 23. Next slide, please.
80% of the General Fund expenditure budget consists of personnel
cost. The remaining 20% is non personnel
costs that include inner fund accounts, CSMART,
support supplies and services.
Next slide, please.
99% of the building security fund expenditure
budget is non personnel and it includes contract
security services. The remaining 1% of the budget is
personnel and is related to the retiree health benefits cost.
Next slide, please. The majority
of the court technology fund expenditure budget is nonpersonal.
It includes software and hardware licensing,
maintenance costs, CSMART support and other planned technology
enhancements. The remaining 18% is personnel
cost. Next slide, please.
90% of the local Tourancy Prevention and Diversion
Fund expenditure budget is personnel costs.
The remaining 10% is non personnel cost,
including education and training supplies, as well as
teen court and student engagement activities. Next slide.
This worksheet provides an overview of the expenditure net
change between the FY 22 and the
FY 23 General Fund budgets.
FY 23 reflects a 2.2% increase in
expenditures. This increase is due to the resumption of dockets
and the related increases in court services,
noticing jury cost, postage language services,
variances in the inner fund accounts, pension and health benefit
rates, and the two Hope 3% increases. Next slide,
please. This slide provides our FY 23
expenditure highlights for the General Fund.
We will continue to maintain the court CSMART System
fund, contractual increases in the security and armored car service,
language services, passport program costs, and citation book
printing. Next slide, please. This slide
provides expenditure highlights for our four special revenue
funds. Expenditures in these funds include contract security
services, technology maintenance and enhancement cost,
and Truancy prevention services. Two of these four funds
include personnel cost. Next slide.
This concludes the budget portion. Now we'll proceed to the next section
of this presentation. The next section of the presentation will highlight
other department level information. Next slide,
please. This list provides more detail
regarding our citywide interfund our citywide restricted
accounts. Sorry. Next slide, please.
The MCD organizational chart on this slide includes our
leadership team and lines of direct and indirect
reporting. Next slide.
The information provided here reflects the diversity of our
municipal court team. Next slide, please.
I am pleased to be able to share with you some of our major accomplishments
from this past year on the next two slides. While we remained
operational throughout COVID Pandemic, we suspended regular
dockets and jury service for over a year. This resulted
in a large number of our cases that needed to be reset and rescheduled.
We have worked diligently since then, resuming dockets from
last April to reschedule these cases, handle the volume of
new cases, and maintain lower docket levels to meet safe distancing
requirements. We also summoned jurors at a reduced level
and found a solution for masking by implementing a clear
mask option for the jurors selected for trials.
Our Passport program is celebrating its first year
anniversary. To date, our Passport program has assisted
almost 3000 individuals to obtain their passports and
has generated $115,000 in that year.
I'm extremely proud of our staff who has worked very hard to obtain their
certification as passport agents and their dedication to the
success of our program. Our program has been recognized
by the US. Department of State for excellent customer service
and for increasing the availability of this public
service. Next slide. In order
to better serve our other areas of our community,
the Juvenile Case Manager Program expanded its Truancy
prevention services to include the Aldine Independent School District
this past year. Our Deferred Payment Program was
recently recognized by the Government Collections Association of
Texas as being the most innovative collection program
for 2021. This program has a great team of
dedicated staff who work very closely with individuals
who need time to pay their fines and who track cases through the successful
compliance. Court security remains at the forefront in
our today's challenging environment.
McD's Court Security Committee includes
broad range of internal and external participants,
and we meet monthly to discuss security related issues.
Next slide, please. The major unmet
need for MCD is the replacement
of our central facility. We suffered major
damage from Hurricane Harvey almost five years ago.
Our court staff has been extremely flexible and
several workarounds have been implemented, including doubling up in
courts, doubling up in offices, sharing workspaces,
and dealing with additional flooding and infrastructure
failures as they arise and occur throughout the building.
We are currently working very closely with the Mayor,
GSD, Finance and FEMA to find a permanent solution
for this ongoing facility replacement project.
Next slide, please. This concludes the
presentation of our FY 23 budget. Just wanted to
thank my entire court team. They have been resilient and positive throughout
this entire five years, doing the things that were necessary
to keep the courts up, to keep the courts running, to keep the courts operational,
and they have been doing an excellent job. And I would also like
to thank the mayor, all of you council members for your continued support
and my partner departments as GSD. Sometimes they let me knock
out a wall, sometimes they won't. But we have done
everything we can to keep the courts at the central location up and
running for our citizens of Houston. And at this time, I welcome any
questions you have. Thank you. Judge, do you have any insight
on our site and release initiative? How many cases come
to courts based on the site and release program?
Site and release? Yes.
They never come to municipal court for Class C misdemeanors?
No, sir. Okay.
All right. What about the associate judges positions?
Have we filled those or how are we looking for the Associate
municipal court judges? We are still going through
the boards of commission to see who is applying. To date,
we really don't have very many applicants because we are looking
for more applicants for the Associate Judge position.
I think I have contacted Jackie
and the newest person there who took Maria's place,
and we're still trying to get applicants in. If you could send
additional information to my office again like you all did earlier
in the year so we can reach out to our networks to see if we
can get some people to apply, we'll do great
council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you, Vice Chair.
Judge, I think you've spotlighted all
of the challenges that the municipal courts continue to face,
again, distinct from criminal and civil.
But going back to the accomplishments you listed, I know when
we've been talking at Public Safety Committee night court,
team court,
all of the different efforts to meet people
where they are, make sure they aren't unduly penalized
and do right by them and do right by the city
and law enforcement. Right. So I just want to give you all credit for that
really quickly on the building, because you mentioned that.
Talk to us about some of those challenges, if you can.
Again, we are still dealing with the
impacts of Harvey COVID, the structural
damage. But what is that doing to the court process?
The ability to function day to day.
When Harvey hit, it wiped out the entire basement, as everybody
knows. And we had six courts, I think, in operation.
We had a bonding section, parking section, the bailiffs,
we had different offices there. So all of those offices
had to move somewhere. And the only court
we had on the first floor was one court. And we have all of
the cashiers and their departments
there. The second floor had courtrooms. And so we
have staff that we have renovated closets
to put supervisors in.
We have judges that are doubling up with courts and court dockets.
We have done everything we could to maintain the
atmosphere of a court that's friendly and safe for everyone.
And then came COVID. And with COVID you can't
stand close to each other. So it took the limited amount
of space we had in the courtroom and cut it in half.
And so that's how we have been operating now,
but we're opening back up into sitting next to each other.
But I have been mandated by the Supreme Court
and I've given the authority to have everyone wear
a mask because we see 2000, 3000 people a day. I just
think it's safer that way for the employees. And I appreciate that because
more shutdowns are going to create a further backlog. So I
completely get that really quickly.
In terms of other needs, concerns for the future,
talk to me about truancy prevention and how that's going.
Our truancy prevention is basically
we have a fund from we have grant funding and we
started out with grant funding that was
around the $700,000 range. We have
seven juvenile case managers that operate under that grant.
We have now submitted a request for
additional grants and right now it's pending approval
temporarily. They're saying that we may get 100,000.
If we just get 100,000. There may be some other options we
have to have to go to do so. That is an unmet need because for
the school district to have juvenile case
managers in there who know the kids if they come to
teen court, the defendants who come to teen court, chances are a
juvenile case manager knows that kid.
And if we have to cut it, it's going to
be a disservice, I think, to our youth.
I just received word on the way yesterday
to Teen Court's final thing that I do believe.
I don't know if he is my first, but one of the first
juveniles student volunteers that came through Teen
Court is about to graduate from the University of Houston's Law School.
So I was very proud of that.
But if the Juvenile case managers,
if we have enough money to keep
what we have, we can work. But I'm not really sure we're going to be
able to keep what we have with just that amount of grant funding.
So are you saying that we may lose the 700,000 that we
currently have? 700,000 is what they
started off giving us. Then we went down to 500 and
now the proposed is 125,
I think you're saying is the Truancy program as is cannot continue.
We have seven JCMS that are funded there. We may be
able to fund three, but four we may lose.
If you could keep us apprised of that,
I would very much appreciate that.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, Chair judge
Marshall, thank you for being here. In your final page
of your final slide of your appendix
and your final bullet on that final page,
you asked a mouthful, stating, in partnership with
the Mayor's office, Finance, GSD and FEMA, we continue
to seek an agreeable option for the replacement of the Central Court
facility. Do you have anything to add to that,
please, council members? Can we
get your support as well? You have my support.
I think our hands are basically tied by FEMA
right now. For them to say, yes,
we'll give you this funding, or no, we won't give you this funding,
or yes, we're giving you some. And it has been like
so there are some plans out there, Judge, as you know.
And I guess what I'm asking you is if you have anything more to add
and it sounds like we're in a pattern.
Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you, Judge, and Miss Santos for your presentations.
And you are dismissed. Thank you. Thank you.
And also thank you to your entire staff, your whole team back there, everyone who's
in the chambers and not here. Thank you all for everything you do as well.
We will now move into the public comment period. I will start
with the virtual speakers. Please press star six to unmute when you hear
your name. The first speaker is Ms. Saba Blanding.
Hey, good afternoon again. I had a
couple of questions. The first is, is there a
plan to extend and expand the Safe Harbor Court
from a public safety presentation? Last year, we had processed around
1000 with 500,000 cases outstanding.
How many people have been served in comparison to the eligible
population? And then my second question
is in regards to the truancy prevention initiatives.
I'm curious what organizations and departments are collaborating in
truancy prevention initiatives. Are there others in the
Houston ecosystem to engage for compassionate approaches
to truancy prevention?
So for great questions, the first one, we're going
to take that question and get a response from you
regarding the Safe Harbor courts. So please submit
that in writing over to District E at
district E at Houst Gov and we'll get back to you
shortly. Your second question on the truancy.
I know that my Brother's Keeper, as well as the Credible Messenger
program that we initiated last year, are working in collaboration with
the municipal courts on the truancy issues.
They do collaborations with the wraparound service and college
counselors at some of the high schools.
So they are working in tandem with
different stakeholders and community groups on enhancing
that program and trying to make sure that it's beneficial for the
youth. Okay.
Thank you. You're welcome. Amanda she.
Hi, thank you. It feels like a theme
across a lot of these budget
presentations, like from the Health Department, department of Neighborhoods,
things like that, is we're losing a lot of budget
in terms of support for the youth.
And I think this is just a statement, really. It just feels
like a really great loss in a time when
there's already so much for the kids to overcome what
was having lost a lot of support with
the schools and things like that. Yeah,
I just wanted to highlight that. Thank you for highlighting
that. And also be mindful that outside of just the city
of Houston, there are many nonprofits
and different organizations with youth emphasis that we collaborate
with all of our offices, kind of work with some of these neighborhood and
after school program groups that are focused on youth engagement.
And so although some of the funding may not be there through the city
of Houston, there are still ways in which we partner with
a lot of great agencies that are still doing similar wonderful work
for the youth as well. The next speaker is Jason Oliver.
I want to pick up where Amanda left off.
I have worked closely with my brother's Keeper on
initiatives, and it looks like we're set to lose it from the Health Department.
And I remember looking at all those that were
green, right, that were funded from the general fund,
which was a small portion in comparison to the red
that were not funded. So, yes,
there are a lot of programs in the community and right and like private programs
and such, but one of the important things that somebody has brought up
before during these workshops is like the consistency when
you have a city entity or a city agency
that's putting these things forward. So I just really think it's
important to be especially as we're talking about focusing
on crime and a lot of this deals with youth and touches
youth and it's hard to find programs and consistent
programming for youth in many spaces and areas
around the city that's in no way equitably distributed. So I just
want to flag that and then I'm trying to figure out
what's going on with Site and release. She said that it doesn't touch
the municipal courts. I'm not a lawyer, so I don't understand
why that is, but I was hoping that there would be some changes that
have been made as a result of Site
and Release adoption that we can see here in the municipal courts.
Great questions. I too am involved
with my Brother's Keeper program. I can tell you that that
as you know, was started through the Obama administration. So many of
the funds that came through for that initiative, not only for the
City of Houston, but all around the country, were federal dollars that we find
matching grants and then can also provide dollars through our
Council District service funds for specific initiatives in our
district. So that's always been a program that we relied
on for outside dollars. When it comes to
the neighborhood programs and nonprofits
regarding the youth, many times through
my experience, they actually do a much
better job of being consistent
with the youth that they see. They're right there in
those neighborhoods, in those schools, so they understand the dynamics
of each of those communities. And many times for the city,
we rely on partnering with them because they have
more of a boots on the ground and wider perspective on what are
the specific needs for those kids and those programs.
And so although the City of Houston may not put
forth some of those programs, we definitely try to support in as many ways as
possible many of our offices allocate dollars
towards the Case for Kids program with Harris County, which does
tremendous work for after school programming and extracurricular
activities for the youth. So we'll continue to
do that. But if there are specific programs that
you have highlighted or identified in the presentations that you
think we need to allocate more resources
towards, then of course, please let us know that as well and
then we'll get an answer to you on the site and release, because I have
similar questions. I was to the impression that since it was a
citable offense that it would be at the municipal court level,
but I may be wrong on that. So we're going
to get some clarification and then we'll provide that feedback as well.
So to ensure we get it to you in a prompt fashion,
if you would email that directly to District E at houst
gov and we'll get a response and
that will complete our public Speakers for the
Municipal Courts budget presentation.
Before we adjourn, please note that budget workshops have
concluded for all City of Houston departments. We will have
our next BFA Committee meeting on Tuesday, May 31 at
10:00 a.m.. I want to give a shout out to all the community members
who took time to come in person and speak virtually
on these topics. Your engagement was beneficial.
It was of value to us. We learned from you,
and we will get any answers that have been unanswered to you.
Shortly. A reminder to all council members to
be checking SharePoint for uploaded presentations,
as well as responses for any questions submitted.
Thank you again to everyone for being here today, and this meeting is
adjourned.